you might have heard about this the
nuclear negotiations with Iran looks
like it's moving forward a little bit we
the p5 plus one we got a deal there's a
lot to do here so I'm gonna try to break
it down simply because I feel like this
is what's getting lost everyone's just
immediately like yeah it's great or it's
awful so let's let's break it down a
little bit here's what the US and the p5
plus one got Iran is going to neutralize
all their twenty percent enriched
uranium they can't enrich uranium over
five percent and must dismantle
equipment that can do so so they can't
build more this is centrifuges and
things like that and they're gonna get
daily IAEA inspections here's what Iran
got 4.2 billion in overseas assets
unfrozen 1.5 billion in sanctions lifted
and the u.s. implicitly acknowledges
Iran's right to enrich there's already a
debate about this Iran is saying that
they got the the right to enrich the
u.s. is saying not quite and we got a
little more for you here's just some
reasons why it might work China and
Russia are on board so we have a bigger
international group backing this it
meets the Iranian demand for the West to
acknowledge its right to enrich as and I
just said that seems to be a little up
for debate at the moment and unfreezing
of assets is tied to Iran Iranian
compliance so they have to actually do
some things to get some of these assets
back and here's some reasons why it
might not work it only last six month
the permanent deal might be tougher so
this could last a little bit and then
fall apart many countries most of the
neighboring countries Israel Saudi
Arabia Bahrain Qatar Kuwait the United
Arab Emirates they're all skeptical and
those are the guys that basically live
on their borders there's opposition both
in d.c between the Senate of Congress
and in Tehran and it ignores non nuclear
issues funding for terrorism they fund
Hezbollah in Lebanon they're funding
Assad in Syria and all kinds of stuff
okay so it's a lot of information but
that's pretty bare-bones
stuff how do you feel about the deal in
it we'll just start with the general end
of it look I like the concept of
diplomacy but I am concerned I mean one
of my greatest concerns is yeah I'm all
with the daily inspections but it still
doesn't sound like real verification to
me I mean I do have very serious
concerns about that and also like you
said it the last points a big one to me
it doesn't address the non-nuclear
issues which are still very very much
concerning you know it that's not the
only issue is the possibility of a
nuclear bomb right so everyone's
ignoring that part of it that you know
right now they have this American
hostage right now they are they have
three ok so there's three American
hostages don't even know about the other
two three American prison okay so so
they've got three Americans in prison so
we didn't address that we didn't address
the Hezbollah issue we didn't address
arming assad and all that so a lot of
people are saying that that's legit
we're not addressing immediate concerns
but is this sort of how negotiations
have to work that we had to give up some
stuff too
well i hope i hope not there's so much
air I don't even know where to begin
first of all on the three Americans in
prison truth be told I work with one
trying to help Amir Hekmati get out of
prison okay I don't think that this deal
should ever deal with Americans in
prison there are two separate issues and
we should not put our government in the
position of negotiating for prisoners
right we don't do it we shouldn't expect
others to do it that's not a very basis
because this is a nuclear issue this is
very serious national security issues
this is not something that we want to
trade prisoners for that will encourage
someone to grab an American next time
and then we have to negotiate for that
American so I would immediately put that
aside I'm sure the family is not happy
that I'm saying that the simple fact on
this deal is though we have six UN
Security Council resolutions already
passed that are very clear that say Iran
must stop enriching all uranium right
Russia and China are on board with that
so this agreement is not greater
international support we already had
Russia and China on board this agreement
is less than the UN Security Council
agreement this is weaker than the UN
when you are weaker than the UN you've
got a really big problem I don't buy
that you have to do this just for
negotiations like your point on the
daily inspections is a really good one
because it's not really daily
inspections of anywhere we want to go
it's daily inspections where they tell
us to go okay so that's the part that's
so the try let's talk about the trust
thing here because right so they can say
yeah you can inspect this building today
or this
heavy water reactor today but we have
stuff over here that you can't see and
we've already been through this with
North Korea so it's part of the
excitement over the deal is that just
most people just sort of don't
understand like it sounds good all on
paper but then actually how it works
people are excited that it that there's
engagement for the first time in 30
years I think people are excited that
there's been a 15-minute phone call and
now that there's you know handshakes and
embracing and and it looks like
diplomacy but I do tend to agree with
some of the things you know both of you
guys are saying especially some stuff
Rick is saying I don't think I think we
gave too much and we got too little and
and I think that's ultimately any deal
is not necessarily a good deal a deal
yes that's good that's a step in the
right direction
and I appreciate John Kerry saying it's
just that a step and we've got the six
months to go further but it does feel
like they got a little more than wonder
why Hillary didn't do this deal because
she was against it really oh she's not
going to negotiate with Iran let's be
very clear about something that the
media is not telling us we have
negotiated on this for a very long time
in 2006 we started with a deal the
international community was united and
what President Obama did was undercut
the entire international community to
pretend like he got some new deal and
that we're talking with them for the
first time yes the Americans are talking
with the Iranians directly but make no
mistake we've been talking in a group
for a very long time and the world has
been united we just lessened the demand
so what do you say to the people that
say well just the talking is good this
whole thing that's happening on Twitter
you know I've been very vocal about how
I think the whole Twitter thing is a
ridiculous because there it's blocked
Twitter is blocked in Iran so Ronnie and
Zarif they're all tweeting to us in
English yeah a YouTube video and I was
like great can you open up the Internet
in Iran so that your people can actually
see your videos it's all a farce so they
keep trying right so they're telling us
about this charm offensive except were
the only ones seeing it so it seems to
me that if you really were behind the
people of Iran you would be fighting at
first let's how about we just give them
Facebook and then we'll go okay well now
maybe we trust you because they don't
seem to trust their own people enough
vote but yet we should present our core
issue is whether or not they
have the right to enrich okay and
already today we heard the Iranians come
out and say we're so thankful that we
have the right to enrich when the White
House is saying no you don't
and now the Iranians are calling the
White House a liar it's four days in
Dave we've already fallen apart unless
agreement so I think what John Kerry
would say to that is well we can just
ratchet up the sanctions again after six
months but I don't think you agree look
a lot of people think that they're two
to three months away from breaking out
and this neutralizing their twenty
percent enriched uranium is a lot of BS
because you can neutralize what we know
you have we don't know what else is
behind the curtain and if you neutralize
a little you can ramp it up pretty fast
what we don't know I think there's some
times when we all talk about this stuff
we can only get the information that's
being disseminated to us and look it's
already come out that they were
negotiating privately for a long time so
is there a little bit of futility in
sort of the day-to-day discussion of
this stuff unless you're sitting in the
meetings right there right and that's
the part about it that you know I want
to get behind it my emotionally it
sounds really good to me but I don't
know maybe it's the defense lawyer in me
I'm just always anticipating what I
don't know and what we're not seeing as
a nation and like you said Dave they
don't even trust their own people so I
don't know how I can trust anything
you're telling me right so what could we
do to then empower the people and not
empower the regime because no one's I
haven't heard anybody even the most
people the farthest people on the right
I haven't heard anyone say they're
against the people of Iran people want
to be free well what we could have done
is we could have supported the Green
Revolution when they took to the streets
but instead President Obama said we're
not going to get involved so he took a
pass at supporting the people and he's
supporting the government now so I think
President Obama is doing the exact
opposite what he should be doing if you
want to bifurcate the people from the
government support the people don't play
into the government's lame messaging I
mean it's just they're not a bunch of
moderates rouhani tweets and our entire
media go crazy because it's Sweden but I
cannot believe that that everyone
retweets it like oh my god this is so
great except I can't see it it's because
we're so thirsty for the idealism behind
you yeah but
Twitter there are some great people to
follow that our inside Tehran that are
doing you know and I'm not talking about
Thomas funk from the New York Times yeah
I mean I think he's terrible he's part
of the the problem but there are people
on Twitter that are really good to
follow that are inside Iran that are
giving you really unfiltered information
because there are ways to get around it
now I'll get some of those names and
we'll put them in the in the description
so my last thought on this is I think
it's also a little bizarre that you know
countries that don't border Iran seem
pretty thrilled about this so US and
England and France and Germany and
Russia etc but all the guys around them
are going this is not good I mean the
fact that Saudi Arabia and Israel
suddenly seem like allies is crazy so
how do we should we be giving a little
more credence to the neighbors that are
right there I think so because again
there's there they at least have a
likelihood of seeing a lot more truth
than we're seeing we're just too far
removed from it and I agree
the enemy of my enemy is my friend and
that's clearly what we're seeing with
this really right but and it that gives
me more pause like I'm already looking
at around sideways right you know and
and now that your closest geographical
neighbors are so adamantly of fearful
and opposed to it gives me even further
policy we got to give them some credence
on that our allies don't trust us and
our enemies don't fear us anymore and
it's a really sad commentary on the
Middle East but you know I look at
Turkey and Jordan and you know Lebanon I
think is one of the saddest stories of
the Middle East we we we pushed the
Syrians out of Lebanon to give Lebanon a
chance in the Bush administration and
now the Syrians are back in Lebanon
Lebanon has fallen apart all because of
the Syria Iran problem and now we just
empowered Iran the Lebanese are left out
yeah all right so finals have thought on
this because we could talk about this
forever probably so what would you say
to the people that would say heard
everything you just said right there and
say well what's the alternative war
because that's sort of the way it's
being framed right now either we had to
take this deal or war was coming nobody
wants war but the simple fact is you
have to ask yourself a very tough
question do you want a nuclear-armed
Iran and I think you know the president
President Obama says no everyone has
said no
the reality is the facts show they're
really close to a breakout six months of
them pulling our chain could be the
difference of them breaking out so
sanctions are not going to work any
longer it's too late for sanctions I
think the fact of the matter is if you
don't want a nuclear-armed Iran you're
gonna have to have some sort of action